so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about the Green Lantern Hal
Jordan and what I'm hoping here is that
at the end of this video you'll have a
strong understanding of his character as
well as how his publication history has
changed over the years
created by John Broome and Gil Kane in
1959 and first appearing a DC showcase
issue number 22 Hal Jordan came out of
the Silver Age resurgence of comics
regarding interest and superheroes
because the reintroduction of the flash
is Barry Allen was so well received by
fans and in turn launched the Silver Age
of comics DC editor Julius Schwartz look
to continue the trend of bringing back
Golden Age heroes by reintroducing the
Green Lantern however because the
original series featuring Allen Scott
was cancelled due to poor sales Schwartz
ought to bring Green Lantern and on a
new platform without starting a new
series and potentially losing money to
this end Schwartz use the showcase line
as a way to experiment with the Green
Lantern concept due to the fact that
fans were already familiar with the
series because like braving the bold DC
showcase was also used to introduce
characters with a series of mini stories
however with Alan Scott's abilities
rooted in magic and because science
fiction was gaining popularity in pop
culture with heroes like Superman
incorporating this concept into his own
publications DC elected to route Hal
Jordans powers in the element of
science-fiction as well while
maintaining what it was that made Allen
Scott popular during his premiere in DC
showcase unlike most of the remaining DC
lineup Hal Jordan did not originally
have an origin story instead the events
simply picked up with him being depicted
as an employee of ferris Air Base
introducing house future love interest
Carol fares in the process her character
operated as an interim boss under her
father Carl Ferris establishing a
possible romance between the two and the
midst of their flirting a pilot
broadcast over the air that his engine
is having troubles and is stalled out
dawning is Green Lantern costume Hal
Jordan recites the infamous oath of the
Green Lantern Corps and brightest day in
blackest night no evil shall escape my
sight let those who worship evils might
beware my power Green Lantern's light
taking to the sky and saving the jet
Gruman Cain used the first issue to
incorporate the idea of hard light
constructs from the original Green
Lantern series into this comic using as
ring to investigate the cause of the
problem Hal Jordan discovers that
radiation is being emitted from an
unknown source directly to the plane
which seems to be responsible for the
mechanical failure
traveling to its source Hal Jordan
discovers that a group had intentionally
sabotage a plane for reasons unknown in
addition during the conflict with the
villains Bruin Kane established the
weakness of Hal Jordan and the form that
his ring is unable to affect anything
with the color yellow
this is discovered when one of the
villains picks up a yellow lab and
throws it at Hal Jordan which hits him
after his rings failed to repel it
taking the next step as the villains
flee in a yellow car Hal Jordan confirms
that he's unable to manipulate anything
yellow when he tries to stop the car but
fails and targeting the wheels instead
Hal Jordan is able to incapacitate the
vehicle and as the criminals try to
escape he uses his ring to capture the
group and turn them over to the nearest
FBI office transitioning back to the
Feres airbase with Caroline her father
Carl celebrating the capture of the
criminals Carl makes the announcement
that because carol has consistently
demonstrated the ability to manage the
office effectively he's basically
turning the facility over to her and in
turn spending the next two years
traveling the world as a result the
previous romantic interest between Carol
and Hal is replaced by Carol viewing the
relationship as employer and employee
until the return of her father allows
Carol to step away from the business
nature of her involvement with Hal now
following this initial story the
reception from fans was excitement due
to seeing the expansion of the existing
superhero lineup because DC was
initially unable to determine whether or
not the popularity of the Green Lantern
was due to the comic boom of the Silver
Age as opposed to genuine interest in
how as a character his stories remained
part of the DC showcase line for two
more issues after which he was rolled
over into his own solo series with Green
Lantern issue number 1 however because
the standard for superhero stories had
been established by Batman and Superman
and that DC's main focus was on
character centric arts as opposed to
title wide crossovers room and Kane had
to play catch-up by establishing an
arch-nemesis for Hal Jordan in addition
to the basis behind his powers to this
end DC launched a nine part series
titled Sinestro Returns with issue
number one providing an origin story
that picked up with the current events
and established a story of how it was
that how had gained his reign in this
origin Hal Jordan is piloting an
experimental plane when his body goes
limp due to a sudden loss of
energy at the same time this energy
drill is revealed to be due to the
guardians of the universe duplicating
house energy in an effort to provide two
versions of him in two separate
locations one on earth piloting the
plane and one that's transported to OA
explaining that their abduction of Hal
is due to their desire to determine his
worthiness to be a Green Lantern the
Guardians provide us with a short
backstory in saying that the former
Green Lantern of sector to a t14 named
AB and Sewer had crash-landed after
being exposed to yellow radiation waves
from the Sun and in turn his power ring
had searched the planet Earth for
replacement while in the middle of
experimenting with a test plane Hal
Jordan was captured by the Green Lantern
ring and brought before Evans sore and
forming how that he had been selected
due to his fearlessness Allen source
states that the purpose of the Green
Lantern's are to protect their sectors
with unwavering bravery against any foe
establishing an inherent weakness for
Hal Jordan in order to provide stories
where he could be defeated Reuben Cain
had a band sir direct how's attention to
the green lantern battery core which
charges the ring for 24 hours but
contained a yellow impurity that keeps
the Green Lantern ring from affecting
anything in a yellow color spectrum an
addition to this if the impurity were
removed it would be power the battery
resulting in Hal Jordan losing the
abilities that came with it and so with
AB and Sewer succumbing to his injuries
Hal Jordan Don's the ring and
demonstrates his powers using willpower
as a basis Hal Jordan demonstrates the
abilities to lift massive objects in
addition to create hard light constructs
in a multitude of ways as a result the
guardians of the universe deem Hal
Jordan worthy of wielding the Green
Lantern ring and return him to earth
after wiping his memory of their meeting
and so with issue number 7 titled the
day 100,000 people vanished all of these
elements came together with the first
appearance of Sinestro originally
depicted as a Green Lantern for space
sector one four one seven Sinestro had
become drunk with his own power and
established a citadel for himself on the
home planet of Cora rather than
upholding the law and ensuring that
justice was maintained
Sinestro established himself as a king
and in doing so only dealt with the
problems he deemed worth his attention
stripping Sinestro of his ring due to
his violation of the Green Lantern oath
the Guardians banished him to the planet
chord in the antimatter universe where
all of his inhabitants were evil
believing that this would result in a
personal Reformation or the very least
keep him
to a single location instead sinestro
joined with a race called the weaponers
which had previously faced Hal Jordan on
three separate occasions and failed each
time with Sinestro and the weaponers
working as allies the group developed a
Weiser teleporter and while monitoring
Hal Jordan during a mission in Vail Dale
City kidnapped him along with everyone
else
using the citizens as hostages Sinestro
demands that Hal Jordan hand himself
over I quiescing so long as the citizens
to return to Earth Sinestro agrees after
which he encapsulates Hal Jordan in a
large yellow sphere of energy because he
had previously been a member of the
Green Lantern Corps and understands a
function of their power
Sinestro states that once Hal Jordans
ring runs out of energy following the
24-hour charge he'll be defenseless
at which point the group will dispense
with him while the power of his ring was
unable to penetrate the bubble due to
the yellow impurity how realized that he
was able to breathe due to the fact that
the subatomic particles of carbon
dioxide and oxygen were able to exit and
enter the sphere using this logic how
condensed the power of his ring down to
the atomic level and used it to speed up
the clock and church Sinestro into
believing that the 24 hour time period
had expired releasing Hal from the
sphere with the expectation of killing
him Sinestro was attached by how who
sealed him in a green bubble making him
a prisoner on the planet cord following
this as the final part of the story arc
and issue number nine groomin Cain
brought Sinestro back in the story
titled battle of the power rings by
providing sinister was own ring in
addition to introducing the Green
Lantern Corps as well as a central power
battery for the first time in the series
as a follow-up from issue number 7
Sinestro established that he had been
prepared for situation in which Hal
Jordan defeated him as a result he had
commissioned the weaponers to develop a
yellow power ring capable of overcoming
the Green Lantern due to their inability
to affect the color yellow using this
ring to escape the Green Lantern's fear
that how had left him in Sinestro
arrived on earth and imprisoned Hal
Jordan in a yellow box using his ring to
change his appearance to look like how
himself
Sinestro left earth in order to join the
Green Lantern Corps during a meeting
where they exchanged information on the
way to use the Rings as well as the
various enemies that they faced creating
a giant monster as a distraction
Sinestro charged his own ring with the
energy given off by the Green Lantern's
during their battle and after gaining
the energy necessary travelled 200 with
the intention of killing the guardians
escaping from his prison Hal Jordan
charges the
travels to OA to do battle with Sinestro
and so during the conflict also
necessarily yellow ring initially proves
to be the strongest how comes to the
realization that sinestro's ring is
charged using green lantern energy
providing a burst of his own power Hal's
able to overtake Sinestro shattering his
ring and the process with the rest of
the Lantern Corps coming to his aid
after defeating the monster the group
realizes that Hal has already overcome
Sinestro
however because their various conflicts
have drained their rings power the group
uses what energy they have left to take
Sinestro to OA as a prisoner and
recharge using the central battery core
with their freshly charged rings the
Green Lantern Corps imprison Sinestro
and sends him into the depths of space
confined within a Green Lantern tube now
following these first nine issues the
reception's by fans regarding Hal Jordan
was one of intense excitement while
Batman had demonstrated the strength of
human ingenuity and Superman was the
original comic book superhero from the
Golden Age Hal Jordan represented
something that had never been seen
before and that he could create
constructs that were able to take on any
shape that he desired and where the
original Allen Scott had demonstrated
some of the abilities seen in these new
Green Lantern stories his comics never
dealt with such an expansive universe
continuing this trend Gil Kane and John
Byrne began to create a series of unique
characters the channels Hal Jordan on
both a personal and heroic level with
stories like issue number four teams the
man who conquered sound which saw the
introduction of sonar a villain who
possessed a scepter that allowed him to
manipulate sound for the purpose of
flight telekinesis and casting illusions
while these stories served to provide an
undercurrent for the Green Lantern
mythos during periods with the Lantern
Corps and Sinestro were absent DC also
sought to tap into the element of young
female readers who may have had a
passing curiosity in the series to this
end issue number 16 saw the
reintroduction of the Golden Age star
sapphire in a manner similar to the
Green Lantern and the flash because
Carol Ferris had an on-again off-again
relationship with Hal Jordan and the
story the secret life of star sapphire
Carol is abducted by a race from the
planet Sam Roth which is populated
entirely by women as their tradition
holds whatever the queen of the race
dies a new queen is selected from one of
the occupants in the universe who must
appear exactly like the previous queen
selecting Carol fares the raisin douse
her with the power of the star sapphire
by way of the Royal gem
due to the power that she possesses
Carol Ferris is compelled to follow the
direction of a race and faces the Green
Lantern in an effort to prove that women
are better than men while the battle
between the two was fairly even at the
conclusion of the story because Carol
had failed to defeat the Green Lantern
the Sam Roth's had wiped Carol's memory
and abandoned her on the planet in
search of another Queen but allowed her
to keep her gem using this as a platform
while Carol Farris would go on to
experience several more battles with Hal
Jordan the concept of the Star Sapphire
was carried over to include other women
like delaffei Ron Deborah Camille
Darnell and Jillian Pearlman among
others while this method of storytelling
remained the standard for the Green
Lantern stories because Sinestro and the
Green Lantern Corps weren't constant
threats and the stories do 2dc looking
to establish Hal Jordan his own hero
the sales of Green Lantern comics began
to slump as a result of the increased
popularity of the Batman and Superman
titles while DC had incorporated Hal
Jordan into the Justice League in 1960
as a way to boost his popularity among
readers by 1965 his solo series was
suffering looking to the popularity of
the flash of two worlds crossover in
1961 and the success that came with it
under Gil Kane and Sid Green issue
number 40 saw the return of Alan Scott
as well as the introduction of Crona the
expansion of the guardians of the
universe mythos and the origin of the
Green Lantern Corps and while this story
was mildly successful among fans
the Green Lantern title continued to
slump and sales as a result were DC
introduced Guy Gardner in 1968 with
issue number 59 titled Earth's other
Green Lantern in 1970 with issue number
76 under the direction of DC editor
Julius Schwartz writer Dennis O'Neil was
paired with Neal Adams where they took
over the series in an effort to make Hal
Jordan more socially relevant working
together
the Green Lantern solo series was
canceled and renamed to Green Lantern
Green Arrow where the two heroes teaming
up while these stories are in critical
acclaim for their focus on more real
world elements like issue number 85
snowbirds don't fly which saw Green
Arrow's sidekick speedy coping with
heroin addiction because the civil
rights movement had thrown the race
relations of blacks and whites into the
limelight but had effectively ended in
1968 and 1971 as a way to tap into the
african-american demographic Dennis
O'Neil and Neal Adams introduced Jon
Stewart as another Green Lantern with
issue number 87 titled
where my power however because neither
green lantern or green arrow were wildly
popular among fans despite these changes
in character creations that you will
continue to see mediocre sales and after
issue number 89 the Green Lantern green
arrow series was rolled over into the
flash with issue number 217 through
issue number 219 where the ongoing story
arc was concluded and then canceled
following this DC dropped the green
arrow aspect from the Green Lantern
green arrow name where the series
remained as a backup feature until flash
issue number 246 now in 1976 with Dennis
O'Neil continuing to write the series
and Mike Grell joining on his artists to
replace Neal Adams who had moved on to a
series of sporadic jobs Green Lantern
was taken back out of the flash series
with the titles name returned to Green
Lantern green arrow with the numbering
picking up at issue number 90
maintaining the team of Hal Jordan and
Oliver Queen the story saw a larger
emphasis on spacefaring battles and the
incorporation of the Green Lantern Corps
even if only in a small role this
combined with the rising popularity of
the Justice League during the Jerry
Conway years meant that the Green
Lantern title began to see resurgence in
popularity and by issue number 123 in
1979 Hal Jordan was returned to his own
solo series and Green Arrow was moved to
his own feature in world's finest
continuing to build on the Green Lantern
mythos in May of 1981 writer Len Wein
introduced a three-part miniseries
titled tales of the Green Lantern Corps
which saw all 36 hundred members pulled
together for the purpose of defeating
Corona and his attempts to return to the
universe due to the series popularity
particularly in the realm of members who
had not been seen before in 1982 with
issue number 148 DC began to introduce
stories involving these other members of
the Green Lantern Corps as backup
features that focus on their own
adventures and other sectors because
these stories were so successful and
because fans were slowly beginning to
grow bored of Hal Jordan Lynn Wine tried
to reinvigorate interest in the series
with a story between issues number 172
and 181 titled take this job and shove
it
which saw Hal doin removed his earth
Green Lantern and replaced with Jon
Stewart and issue number 183
while this was short-lived due to the
launch of crisis on Infinite Earths in
1987 following the events conclusion and
the reboot of DC's continuity with issue
number 200 Steve Englehart had taken
over for Len Wein and in addition to
rebooting the continuity
we told the origins of the guardians of
the universe and with issue number 201
retitled this series the Green Lantern
Corps and provided earth with seven
Green Lantern members composed of erisa
chip the squirrel Hal Jordan Sean
Stewart cat mat we CELAC and Kilowog who
is introduced in this issue however
because the John Byrne reboot of
Superman had caused a resurgence in the
Man of Steel's popularity as well as
Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns
allowing Batman to overtake Superman in
popularity the new run of Green Lantern
was short-lived with DC canceling the
title after only 24 issues returning in
1990 with volume 3 under the writing of
Gerard Jones and Pat Broderick because
fans were lukewarm to the character in
1993 DC sought to eliminate Hal Jordans
from the series entirely and replaced
him with a more contemporary hero that
could identify with younger fans to this
end Ron Marz was tasked with writing the
three-part series emerald highlight
which would see the villain hank henshaw
also known as cyborg superman engage in
a battle with the Eradicator one of four
characters claiming to be the Man of
Steel following the death of Superman
event during their battle the villain
Mongol attacked KO city and completely
destroyed it with hal jordan off planet
at the time he returned to find his home
destroyed along with most everyone he
knew using his power ring to reconstruct
the city once the power of the ring wore
off he was called before the Guardians
of the Universe and reprimanded for
using his power for selfish reasons
instructed to return to OA and give up
his ring Hal Jordan quite literally cut
a swath of the Green Lantern Corps
killing every single member in the
process arriving on OA
Jordan kills Kilowog Sinestro as well as
all the Guardians
except for gantlet who is kept alive
using the force of the remaining
Guardians during the story DC also
introduced Kyle Rayner as a struggling
artist with Hal Jordan casting aside his
role as a Green Lantern declaring
himself to be parallax and with the
Lantern Corps wiped out gantlet reformed
Hal Jordans ring sent it to earth where
it located an endowed Cal Raina with its
power making him the last Green Lantern
and picking up in the four-part series
titled emerald fallout underwriter Chuck
Dixon former Green Lantern Guy Gardner
having previously acquired Sinestro
yellow power ring became aware of the
Green Lantern's destruction
investigating OA alongside Martian
Manhunter Wonder Woman Darkstar and
others the group found that they had
been led into a trap by Hal Jordan
defeating the group and putting Guy
Gardner in a coma the story led into
DC's attempts to correct lingering
continuity issues following crisis on
Infinite Earths with the story zero hour
crisis in time centering on Hal Jordan
timming to remake reality the events of
the story saw him traveling to the end
of time killing a being named time
trapper who had the power to control
future time and attempt to remake the
universe and his own image while future
stories like 1998 Emeril nights and
1999's day of judgment would see the
time displace Hal Jordan meeting Kyle
Rayner in addition to undertaking the
mantle of the spectre because the sales
of the Green Lantern title were
beginning to slump and his character had
appeared in DC new frontier by Darwin
Cooke and 2004 writer Geoff Johns was
assigned to return Hal Jordan to the DC
landscape with a six-part story titled
Green Lantern rebirth with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and I will catch you guys later
peace